you and J Stone never dropped your
project or in my truck Stone did you
guys end up dropping the project
together
some new [__] me and stone will put it
together that's only right
that's only how many songs do you guys
have that you're sitting on like hard
drives we got a tape
so it's just a matter of we gotta say
but don't be dropping I'll be dropping
he drops a lot for sure you know what
I'm saying like but that's that's family
like out of all of the rappers that you
know what I'm saying like I met or I
really crossed paths with me and stone
got a different type of vibe and of
course it came from from nip but we got
our own type of energy type [__] I love
stone is it pretty crazy like
[__] how many years has it been since we
lost nip was it I was 18. February it
was like early 2018. I was March 31st
right before April Fool's 2019 19. yeah
because it was after reaction that we
got a year before shooter so that was
like yeah 19.
um but to just see like how he's kind of
become this like I mean he was always a
legend but he's like a real icon like I
just like we're talking about one of our
interviews Clips just randomly going
viral I just saw Malcolm X you can dive
into like Nipsey reels of interviews
that he's had and just get life lessons
nobody was paying that [__] on mine
while he was here for sure but now you
know I mean that's it's sad that they go
that way but
he really
he really knew what was going on and and
knew how to do this [__] I feel like
more than a lot of people bro a lot of
people jump into this [__] and let the
money or the labels or the or the or the
fame direct how they move like I feel
like I feel like cuz had his own
blueprint on how he wanted to do it you
know I mean like beyond all that extra
[__] like he had his own
I'm gonna do it like this I'm gonna put
these [__] on that I grew up with I'm
gonna start my own [__] I'm gonna do the
store I'm gonna have my brother running
the store like he just had he had a lot
of insight on [__] that like a lot of
[__] don't got and I learned a lot
from him that I applied on my own [__]
right now you know what I mean how is uh
you you kind of are also becoming as
well known as an actor as you are an
artist because there's some people who
discovered who you are through acting
Who acting facts
um obviously you're a [__] rapper
you're a rappers rapper but like uh how
a lot of [__] are you diving in on the
acting all the way all the way that's
the [__] that had an old white ladies in
the in the in the airport
like [__] that I didn't get from rap you
know with rap I already certain [__]
with rap like I know if I walk in this
Popeyes you know someone's gonna know
this predominantly black or Spanish like
somebody gonna spot me like but when I
go through the airport and there's like
an older white lady or the younger Asian
kid or you know I mean like it just be
so many different
races that you know I mean that that
that tapped into me acting and I feel
like it just kind of like
brought in my rap [__] even more like it
kind of just built this [__] like it put
it out more are you like going well [__]
are you on strike right now
strike one for acting are you on strike
I ain't on no strength are you a part of
sag after I'm more sag but I ain't yeah
you're on strike you didn't even know it
you're stuck right now hey Dave you're
on strike man I'm hot I'm ready to act
what you talking about no no you're not
don't say that hey if you cannot cross
pick you can't cross the picket line
you signed a waiver already
it's on me too that's crazy that means
you're on strike you know they hold down
your dental you know all that good [__]
they take care of the benefits that's
why you got to stand with sag that's the
union you heard
so I must be on strike you're on strike
you must be on strike you'll go go tune
in the Wu-Tang man it's three seasons of
that [__]